what's going on reject nation greg and
olivia with you today
we watched mulan a couple of days ago
the best review i've seen from mulan has
got to come from double toasted they
perfectly summed up
the feelings we had for that movie one
thing for sure
that we binge watch all the time is ryan
george's pitch meetings
we're gonna watch the live action mulan
one right now and then we'll talk a
little bit about whatever he rips on and
maybe we'll add some of our
own little takes let's do this
so you have an original movie for me oh
well no
no actually i'm just kidding so you have
a live action or incredibly lifelike cgi
remake of an animated classic from the
90s that did really well for us so we
could cash in on nostalgia for me
oh you got me sir i was thinking we
could do mulan amazing now we've been
getting a lot of criticism that our
remakes are just straight up remakes so
we're going to mix things up at least a
little bit here
you know it sir i was thinking we could
take the animated movie and remove all
the
you know fun just take all the joy out
of it
no more mushu the talking dragon i guess
yeah no we're gonna want this to be a
whole lot more realistic so no more
talking animals no more breaking out
into songs
nice just grounded realistic stuff like
people that defy gravity and a witch
that turns into a bird
and she has bird talons when she's in
human form and she can turn into people
and a thousand bats and there's a cgi
phoenix that shows up from time to time
kind of a lot of wacky fantastical
elements there yeah but all the
characters are going to be somber so
it's mature
i guess that makes sense at the
beginning of the movie we're gonna see
her as a child and she's basically
super human oh she is yeah she has the
ability to channel her chi so she's
borderline magic she's had these powers
since she was born
she sure has sir so she's straight up
she's anakin you know she's ray she's
new she's freaking maybelline
oh being born with it is tight yeah yeah
so in this version she's not going to
grow into a warrior through cunning and
hard work and perseverance
no sir she's just the chosen one and
what message do you think that's going
to be sending the kids
i don't know sir but what i do know is
that this is a superhero movie now oh
those make us money so please keep going
so anyway when she grows up she has to
hide all her special jedi powers because
of tradition oh bummer but then these
bad guys they're taking over china so
you know that's not good
and who are these bad guys well there's
this bad guy bori khan who wants to kill
the emperor because he killed his father
and then there's that witch lady who
just wants to fit in oh she does
powerful you can probably take on china
by herself yeah
when i'm in charge you'll fit in so
she's like okay cool
he's actually pretty mean compares her
to a dog oh very disrespectful
let me tell you these bad guys they have
a flare for the dramatic like they line
up in straight lines before battle for
the most dramatic entrances possible
very sassy yeah and they spend a ton of
time on their makeup they're basically
violent theater students anyway so the
emperor wants a man from every household
guys but mulan's dead he's old and
injured so he's probably gonna die
that's not good and so mulan is gonna
secretly go in his place and pretend to
be his son
are we gonna have like a super intense
and emotional montage like in the
animated version where she puts on her
father's armor not really no she's just
gonna kind of go oh
okay so then she's gonna go into
training and meet some other soldiers
and they're gonna have fun personalities
like in the animation no because that
would be fun
right my bad so this commander guy who's
really pushing everybody in training
because if they don't live up to his
expectations they get sent home so
wouldn't mulan's father just have been
sent home if he had gone
oh my god anyway so what else i didn't
even think about that
she's a jedi woman right right and the
commander he makes them do this test
where they have to walk up a mountain
with buckets of water oh and does she
figure out like a smart way to do that
like the pole thing in the animated
movie no at a certain point she just
does it because she doesn't want to hide
her super powers anymore so just
straight up brute strength because of
the power she was born with yeah
yeah i guess that's character growth
lost what yeah like she chases some
people and then she's lost somehow
anyway then she encounters the witch
oh and how does that go well the witch
is like you need to stop lying about
being a woman and then mulan is very
inspired so she heads back into battle
with flowy hair and no armor
she should probably wear some armor
though she's not gonna cause she learned
the art of the dramatic entrance now
the bad guys are like launching
explosives at the good guys oh no those
blow up yeah so before they can fire
another shot she gets on a horse she
picks up a bunch of helmets she travels
across the battlefield behind enemy
lines up the mountain
then sets up the helmet so they think
there's more than one soldier there
how long does it take them to reload oh
yeah that's kind of a lot of stuff huh
maybe she teleports because of her cheek
oh yeah okay sure anyway so then she
tricks them into causing an avalanche
and then gets kicked out of the army for
being a woman
oh dang it and then the witch tells
mulan that there's another attack that's
gonna happen so mulan goes back
and tells the army and they're like okay
you lead the men now
that's so weird later the witch is gonna
tell mulan that the emperor has been
taken and he's gonna be killed
okay so is the witch just verbally
leading mulan to every single plot
in this thing she is yeah oh a very
guidy witch yeah and then
shoots an arrow at mulan and the witch
sacrifices herself in bird form oh
sounds like maybe she should have turned
herself into a thousand bats on that one
pretty emotional moment with the witch
as she's dying why doesn't the bad guy
like
you know shoot another arrow because
there's an emotional scene happening oh
that's super considerate and then
milan's gonna
hit your head before we save the emperor
oh man it's gonna be tough to beat a
badass like him
actually it's gonna be super easy oh
really yeah because she's pretty much
been a superhero this whole time she
uses her super powers to make him fall
off a thing
and then she jumps in the air and kicks
an arrow into his heart oh my god and
then everybody's super happy for her
because she's embodied all the jedi by
kicking a sharpened projectile into a
man's chest it's very nice and so yeah
that's about it what do you think well
it sounds like a lot of
no it doesn't sound fun not gonna be
super fun no but you know it sounds like
it could have cool visuals oh definitely
this thing was made
for the big screen oh
thank god we didn't spend that 30
dollars thanks for watching that pitch
meeting hope you liked it don't know why
i said that all on the same note
if you did like the video please share
and like that helps out a lot and let me
know in the comment section what movies
you want to see pitches for as always
check back soon for a new one see you
guys on the next video
bye bye love how he does his more
sincere voice there
his more sincere voice we check every
weekend for a new picture oh yeah and it
pisses me off that's when i
whenever we're like i see comments on
other people's channels
of where's your new video or something
people commentators get mad and i'm like
guys
give them a break they're hard at work
we only get that way about
one youtuber and that's ryan george's
[ __ ] readings i'm like what the hell
does he put up a video with
it's been one week if he's ever a little
bit late yeah oh
we rain hell in in the car the car where
we're arguing while we're getting our
food you all we're usually yeah to drive
through who's trying to get our taco
bell and
pass the time at that obnoxiously long
line by watching a pitch meeting
you don't really make the slide go
faster a pitch meeting yeah ruined it
ryan george
oh man yeah this movie was uh was a real
letdown
i mean he knocked on pretty much every
single point
that we could have possibly remarked
upon yeah i think we said those things
out loud to each other when we were
watching the movie pretty much
i heard some like not so great things
about the movie but the first 20
30 minutes or so i was like hey let's
just give it a chance just give it a
chance
the second she started kicking and
dancing and
spinning the thingymabobber and showing
her powers you were like
oh so she already has power yeah yeah
it completely strips away the impact of
mulan's journey
it strips away all stakes we thought
personally that the editing and the
pacing
was very off that it was just kind of
like watching
an outline take place there was a lot of
the dramatic beats were not
hitting but we watched this online small
group of people yeah
admittedly we were like the only two
seem to really not like it
the other ones are huge disney fans so
yeah it's kind of like disney can do no
wrong yeah
it was a kind of a confusing movie to me
that i don't really hear too many people
talking about on in this particular
element it seemed to have this approach
where i wanted to talk a little bit more
about being a woman and have some
more feminist commentary which which is
fine
the idea to do that okay that like it's
not the idea that bothers me it's really
the execution of it
especially you know call it chi or call
it superpowers it's pretty much
superpowers in this movie by giving her
powers right up front at the very
beginning of this film
and her never really having to train
or learn all those sequences are just
like
kind of blonde she just knows she's just
a master
and it was so it felt like kind of
sudden when she just takes off her armor
and goes into battle
look at my long flowy beautiful hair
as i'm riding a horse and i'm like
you're going into battlefield you need
that armor
it actually weakens the female
empowerment
impact when she already has her powers
and she didn't do anything to earn that
like when like what ryan george brings
up here about going up on the pole
and having to retrieve that arrow they
have a sequence there where
a guy is you know gearing them up saying
like we're going to make you all men
you're going to become men
so they essentially do the sequence from
the disney movie i'll make a man out of
you song but they just don't have
the musical number there but it's
essentially that's the beat of the movie
but it's not fun it's not fun don't care
about the characters
and there's no impact what's the point
of the training if she already has power
she's already hyper skilled
because in that in the disney movie it's
like oh she
she's being told to go home and then she
starts going up the pole she's earning
it
and she doesn't earn anything in this
movie so it actually weakens the female
empowerment this
movie relies heavily on your nostalgia
for the first film it's strange because
it tries to become like a more
grounded very self-serious version
it's i know like mulan is like the
disney movie it was not
technically the first thing to do mulan
and mulan is based on a real person
blah blah blah let's face reality here
this movie
is an adaptation of the disney one and i
appreciate that they at least
tried doing something different it looks
beautiful it's
shot beautiful sloppily edited in some
parts
it's softly edited the action is
underwhelming jarring
in so many ways the way the plot
maneuvers is kind of just
weird every a lot of it was very strange
and it is like a very somber tone and
it seemed to lack personality for a film
that had so much color on screen
i feel like they had beats they had to
hit and they were like okay we did it
let's go
yay there's no character build up you
don't care about any of the characters
in the film and that's the big bummer
because
i feel like wasn't the animated version
shorter the animated version was shorter
yet this movie pretty much has the same
outline
yeah and you care about the characters
the animated film we don't care about
them here
yeah it was kind of just a really
strange experience so i appreciate this
i feel like double toast that has the
best review on it and this is some of
the funniest commentary i've heard on it
from
from ryan george she knocks it out of
the party this is like a perfect
summation of so much that's wrong with
the film
and i know a lot of times he'll make fun
of movies that are actually great and
he's
pointing out stuff we haven't heard
before but this is like really good
criticism
especially when it feels like it
validates our feelings on the matter
alright guys well mulan did you see it
did you love it
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell subscribe to the
screen ram for more pitch meetings last
but not least
i'm gonna shout out my homeboy jt
because per
tradition if i'm talking about something
that has to do with asian people
i'm gonna shout out the one asian patron
eject at our patreon page
j t keep up the asian buddy
keep being asian never stop
with the asian persuasion
asian i'm half asian so i feel like i
got a leeway to make this joke oh
okay no it's not a joke
don't remove the asian it's a dangerous
procedure
[Laughter]
love talking with you buddy hope you're
enjoying deep blue c3 because that's
apparently what you've been wanting to
watch lately
see you dude